[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais le silence des antilles pour tout
semblant d'hésiter
et quand les enfants mais je suis obligé
de nous
[Musique]
mme ashton a fait et
mettez moi ce qu'on appelait je posais
sur dix ans exit pas ce qui se passe
comme si j'avais 10 ans assombrir la
vision autant de soleil est présent
des gens qui font la morale avec une
vaste horizon vous faites simplement
qu'on ait perdu la raison
la vie un terrain glissant mais dans
quel monde nous vivons est en effet le
mal est fait quand on est père le mal
est fait
[Musique]
c
mais le silence des vins qui vaut tous
semblant d'hésiter
salut je suis obligé de ré
tous les poissons
[Musique]
mais moscou
toujours la télévision oblige épices et
des yeux rien à l'horizon
je racontais mes problèmes à des gens
qui vivent dans les ans ils vont te
prendre au sérieux le fils bush père de
vincent tout simplement j'intéresse pas
comment tu peux être une valeur
marchande non ceux de quelques passes
ans est en effet le mal est fait mais
dans les faits le mal est fait
[Musique]
décoiffant
lycée
[Musique]
dis-moi ce qu'on appelait et
la percée de ne pas profiter du temps
qui nous reste à vivre le pire c'est de
ne pas reconnaître tout ce qui nous
arrive
le pire c'est de ne pas profiter du
temps qui nous reste à vivre le pire
c'est de ne pas reconnaître ces malades
sauf qu'ils vont tous semblant d'hésiter
mais quand les enfants pourquoi
[Musique]
je suis au plus serré
c'est à la baisse
[Applaudissements]
il faut tout simplement des idées éco
les enfants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]